[Music]
the communicator pager the hosts are
only postulate nippy's hey pager clones
is good luck to you did you have a rough
day agent fury I'm gonna need
clarification on this space invasion
sprawls are infiltrating your planet
they're shapeshifters
[Music]
okay prove you're not scroll that's a
photon blast and I was croaking I'll do
that I'm just supposed to take your word
today
we are Cree strong United
remember control
I have this power
but I don't know where it came from
I've never seen anything like her you
think you can find us she's just the
beginning
you've come a long way weakness strong
as you think
what is this announcing your identity on
clothing help with the covert part of
your job said the space soldier was
wearing a rubber suit hey everybody it's
Charlie we got a bunch of new Captain
Marvel footage to break down and more
Super Bowl trailer news that we'll talk
about at the end of the video this
mostly focusing on the comedy of winking
at that infinity war post Crenna seen in
avengers endgame because of the souped
up Captain Marvel space pager we're
still doing the Amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Nick Fury moment
on the video the way Sam Jackson has
been doing press for this movie you
would think that it is solely a Nick
Fury movie he's been talking up his
character quite a bit so I'll explain
what he said about Nick Fury with
Captain Marvel during it but even if you
don't speak Russian you could probably
pick up on what's going on in these
scenes you see a different version of
her at the phone booth tried to make a
phone call but you see finished special
effects with all these special star
charts so it kind of seems like she's
trying to call star force in yawn raagh
to alert them about what's going on with
the Kree in trying to stop their secret
invasion on planet earth because it
seems like she's kind of on her own in
most of these trailer shots where she's
chasing down Scrolls on the Los Angeles
train most of the beginning of the film
seems like it's her with Star Force in
outer space on a separate mission to try
and take down Scrolls so whatever they
learned during these scenes is probably
some special reason for her to go off by
herself back to Planet Earth to try and
chase them down maybe they learned about
the secret invasion and she goes to
investigate the weird thing though is is
that you would think that yawn drawn to
go back to Planet Earth because she
might find out that the Kree had been
lying to her this whole time and they've
been trying to keep this up because
she's so powerful and they want her as
an asset in their war with the scrolls
there's a couple funny scenes of them
with the pager with him fumbling with it
and heard just saying give me the pager
so we can get going you look at her
costume and you can tell this is when
they're inside that special shield base
where they've been looking at all the
records and if you can't tell yes this
is the exact same pager as the souped up
space pager in the infinity war
post-credit scene it's just that it's
just a regular Motorola pager that he's
using for shield government business
during the course of the movie so he
just seems like it becomes a running gag
through the film like he has one for
shield business just like any normal
Special Agent would they keep whipping
it out during different parts of the
film throughout just a communique
first with shields superiors like the
secret Scrolls then once he finds out
what's going on with that he uses it to
communicate with Carol Danvers to
coordinate their plans for getting rid
of all the scrolls and the Cree when she
gets wise to her true backstory then
they probably don't upgrade it to the
super spaced up pager that you see in
the infinity war post-credit scene until
the end of the film when I assumed just
based on what Kevin Feige is saying
where she goes back into kree-skrull
space to continue policing that part of
the universe to ensure that the
kree-skrull war doesn't flare up again
and threaten the rest of the universe or
earth in particular then they have some
funny reference where Nick Fury makes a
one-liner about him contacting her if
[ __ ] ever goes down on planet earth in
case we ever need you in dire
circumstances and he becomes one of
those moments where everybody in the
theatre points at the screen Family Guy
style like ah he said the thing he's
talking about the pager from that
post-credit scene in infinity war samuel
l.jackson was doing a bunch of
interviews recently talking about what
his relationship is like with carol
danvers through most of the film and
it's mostly middle-aged Nick Fury
working threat-assessment for shield
because earth isn't really at the point
where they're assessing threats from
outer space like when he says threat
assessment it's mostly post Cold War
stuff so he's mostly focused on other
nations like Russia China the Middle
East North Korea any typical problem
areas that the US would be worried about
during that era in history he himself
has been long discharged from the
military his prime military years were
mostly during the height of the Cold War
with the Soviet Union so this sort of
where his brains at after the fall of
the Soviet Union he's sitting at a desk
and he's kind of like a soldier without
a purpose anymore like military vets to
spend their whole life just going from
tour of duty to tour of duty back to
back then they're forced to completely
react limit the civilian life and it's
almost like they've lost their identity
until they find some new purpose in life
like I'm not a military person what am I
supposed to do with myself so Nick Fury
is at the end of his rope he's super
despondent he doesn't feel like he fits
in with this new modern shield he's got
this brand-new baby agent called Coulson
who's fresh out of the Academy he's not
sure what to do with when all of a
sudden he's getting ready to retire
early just because he can't deal with
the boredom anymore when Carol Danvers
literally falls into his life through a
blockbuster ceiling so the early film is
him getting the whole spiel from Carol
verse about the kree-skrull war in their
secret invasion it is like wait a minute
you're telling me that you a human
looking woman or an alien warrior from
another planet and you're telling me
that these bad guys the scrolls they can
shape-shift to look like anybody I don't
know how many f-bombs they're gonna give
him during a pg-13 movie but you can see
the points at which samuel l.jackson
would be dropping f-bombs in a typical
movie but it's not so much that he
doesn't believe her right away about all
this crease girl stuff because she
clearly has powers like she blasts the
jukebox with her photon blast so he hops
on board the Captain Marvel train pretty
quickly but the real turn for him is
inside we know they're looking at
records here and then later in the
trailer you see them looking at the body
of the scroll in the table there very
clearly they get into a fight and kill a
scroll that had previously looked like a
human that he probably knew so that's
the moment where he completely believes
her like oh okay yeah this is a real
thing these scrolls are really trying to
infiltrate our government because I
trusted this person like I trusted the
wrong person that I lost my eye in this
scene though he still does have that
other eye he just has an ice pack above
it the problem was trying to figure out
when he loses his eye though is is the
way Marvel lies in trailers just
remember the thor ragnarok trailer in
Thor's two eyes versus one eye you see
Thor on the Rainbow Bridge activating
his full Thunder God powers fully
caffeinated Thor and in all the trailers
he had two eyes if he didn't see the
behind the scenes for how they filmed
those scenes they just put dots around
his eye and when he lost it they would
just Photoshop it out later so he would
walk around on set with two eyes while
they were filming all these probably how
they did all the Nick Fury stuff too
like he always had two eyes walking
around on set it just that you know
after he lost it they put a bunch of
dots around it and then removed it in
Photoshop pretty safe odds that Nick
Fury does not lose that eye in a big
surprise attack when he trusts his wrong
person till the big third act climax
that you see when the biggest stuff
during the movie happens we'll probably
see Captain Marvel go full binary for
the first time then you had like that
big final act battle with her again
outer space just destroying all those
ships with her full powers samuel
l.jackson also put some of these other
trailer moments into context too like he
says that while he is talking to Carol
Danvers and she's giving him the whole
spiel about the kree-skrull war in her
backstory he notices
a lot of weird things about her that
don't make sense like when they're on
the special skip jumper here that looks
like a prototype for the future Avengers
quinjets and she just automatically
knows how to fly it and he's like wait a
minute you're telling me you've never
flown this before but yet you know
exactly how to fly it
something clearly is not right here so
he senses that she's not telling him
everything about her backstory or she
herself doesn't know it so a moment like
this for instance is before she fully
remembers her backstory we also got a
different scene with it but seems like
Maria Rambo in present day helping her
remember things so like you got some
context to this but she's looking at all
these photos in this special house here
she probably tells her hey wait a minute
we used to be Air Force pilots together
and gives her all this backstory there's
also some blurry images that seemed to
imply that there will do a young version
of Monica Rambeau as well there are so
many Easter eggs for her character it
just seems like they imply that
eventually they intend on doing an adult
version of her at some point but of
course they haven't said anything about
that yet because the movie hasn't come
out but Maria Rambo hear her call sign
in the Air Force is Photon and in the
comics Monica Rambeau her daughter takes
the name photon as her superhero name
eventually so there's so many things
that they're looking at here it doesn't
seem like a coincidence that they're
trying to set stuff up for future post
Avengers endgame phase for movies my
guess is if they do Monica Rambeau for
real it won't be to the Captain Marvel
sequel in that movie will be set during
present day obviously but obviously the
big stuff happening later this weekend
is all the Super Bowl trailers brie
Larson is going on Ellen Friday tomorrow
there could be more footage that they're
dropping or there could be some Super
Bowl stuff Disney bought a whole bunch
of Super Bowl ads so most likely
trailers are Avengers endgame
Captain Marvel Toy Story for frozen - in
Aladdin obviously I'll prioritize for
any big Marvel trailers leave your
requests in the comments below there
might be a game of Thrones Season 8
trailer as well from HBO click here to
learn about the new Batman movie in why
Ben Affleck officially left the Batman
role and click here for my new
spider-man far from home sinister six
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see
today
[Music]